you're welcome to this video playing oj3
from Norway and that's what you get for
playing one if for the defense where you
only have big ideas how to play let's
see what happens
c6 yeah this is one of the modern ways
to treat this and would favorite of the
late English I am Tony miles so quite
quite solid way to to treat this opening
black actually has a pretty decent
chances to to equalize it's got decent
development and a healthy porous
structure that is quite similar to the
colour Colin actually okay let's um
let's continue a bit okay I'll take it
I mean the bishop he cannot really
tolerate the night there so he gave me
the bishop pair in effect but of course
some the bishop pair is not such a big
deal in this position yeah he wants to
make sure that this Knight has a good
post
he's securing it with b5 a4 against C
form when a for doesn't have against c4
but B 5 days
and h5m multi-purpose move it helps to
gain some space on the kingside and
maybe at some point I can even think
about playing g4 h5 trapping this bishop
this is actually I think a threat now I
can play can play f6m if I go g4 I can
play of 6 so it's not it's not an
immediate threat ok yeah this is curious
he wants to obviously to get the Knight
to c3 but yeah this should be three this
should be three yeah maybe maybe just f6
interesting
hmm yeah
our Wade f6 I actually have no c5 but
he's got Knight e4 against that
wow what a position interesting yeah d
force hanging and
hmm a very interesting position still
g5f six rook c5 this night if for this
doesn't really help
my dearest play 94g phone I hope this is
working and 94 I can just take it of
course I mean s but I what I was talking
about is f6 rook c5 what Wow do you
think it you really think that you you
are heart it's it's hard to to get
surprised sometimes after all these
years if we should be one what the hell
is this yeah obviously it's just very
greedy and what's to win a to hmm how to
how to play that now very interesting
I'm pretty sure it this is bad but to
refute it is another matter especially
considering the time situation I have
from quite some pieces on the Kings side
hmm can always move the F pawn this is
the real problem g5 is going to play f6
ok let's let's still do that
it's a matter of time also I cannot
spend so much time
I think you must play a six now
everything else is probably not not not
on
I hope to have enough attack now but of
course as usual the time the Sun was a
problem hmm
Bishop if he takes one day to this
Bishop d3 and so on but he's got f5 this
is the problem f5 looks like I'm
shutting down my my attack but not much
choice now as usual very quickly plate
and maybe it's working I certainly would
have invested at least a couple of
seconds but okay yeah yeah black is
winning it should be what
hmm maybe I should have tried mission f4
f5 at least this is really really not
working at his blundering with this
Bishop simply yeah this is without
increment you can play all kinds of
mountains and get away with it
and winning in a position where you are
sure to win on time that's probably
still still okay what still okay for
black
yeah no more chance nine seconds yes
we've got lots of balls be sure to give
for us the only the only slight hope
yeah a one cannot prevent that should be
one what a move yeah I spent lots of
time here already yeah that's a it's a
really good position and yeah and it's
good for black according to the computer
which is pretty shocking this this is
supposed to be good for black and really
before and getting the night down maybe
it is maybe it is even look do you want
is supposed to be good okay what about
this should be one computer one supply
d5 yeah I should have played played the
booth okay here simply to to avoid this
completely dead end on the clock and
yeah this is not working which is not a
big surprise Bishop Bishop d3 Bishop h6
is but the computer wants to play but
you can even play g6 so it's clear that
yeah it's it's not objectively great
yeah it's dead loss in fact any blunder
this but it's still good for black
Bishop III now yeah okay there there are
possibilities to to muddy the waters of
course but I had 10 seconds so no no
chance at all so that you can Nick would
even blunder this piece and didn't run
any any big risk
hmm yeah this is so it's a bit weird
that this yeah it's a technical problem
obviously with the rock getting into
trouble the computer recommends here f6
not be should be one but f6
and after this it says blacks better
really yeah it's Bishop p1 if you look
at the the line that is calculating in
this pointing or B should be one later
and really weird yeah I know I'm
supposed to play d5 yeah but some
there's some logic to that to counter in
the center if you are playing D
centralizing moves but cam didn't didn't
calculate that really and now this one
yeah that's that's some point to it
certainly best move noise Queen c7
really weird yeah still interesting
thanks for watching